[Musique]
la région est connue pour ses bleus est
légendaire et son fiore majestueux un
territoire de plus de mille kilomètres
carrés dont les 150000 habitants
dépendent en grande partie depuis près
de 100 ans d'une seule grande industrie
c'est ici que les promoteurs d'une usine
de gaz naturel liquéfié gnl québec ont
choisi de s'installer
l'objectif c'est d'exporter 11 millions
de tonnes par année gaz naturel qui vont
être en fait à 100% d'approvisionnement
au niveau canadien de l'alberta on va
amener la garantie réelle sa forme
gazeuse ici qu'on vaut liquéfié dans nos
installations
c'est actuellement le plus gros projet
industriel au canada
les promoteurs américains ont prévu
investir 9 milliards de dollars dans ce
complexe industriel
la construction de l'usiné de 2021 à
2025 créerait 4000 emplois directs et
quelques centaines en permanence par la
suite on a tous les services dans ce
militaire à l'université donc on est
capable de vraiment développer une
espère une expertise de gaz naturel un
peu comme ça c'est fait avec la ligne
homme à l'époque on assiste bien depuis
quelques années à la naissance d'un pôle
technologique important dans la
circonscription chicoutimi le fjord
mais cela n'a pas permis de contrer un
exode important des jeunes vers les
grands centres urbains
le député sortant du coin et candidat
conservateur richard martel
ex-entraîneur de l'équipe junior de
hockey avoue que le projet d'une méga
usine de gaz donne des ailes à sa
campagne
c'est à peu près mais jobs dirait qu'il
dirait que ça va amener ensuite d'être
sauvé c'est ça ça va nous donner 100
millions de taxes et d'impôts par année
ça des retombées économiques de 800
millions par année alors si c'est quand
même c'est quand même beaucoup
le parti conservateur appuie à fond le
projet ce qui semble être le cas aussi
pour une majorité d'électeurs
il voit ses frères ses projets la haye à
messi et mieux fait ici avec nous non
alors pourquoi pas le faire ici c'est un
rêve je me tiens il ya 40 ans quand même
pas encore débuté
le président de port saguenay et ancien
ministre stéphane bédard se prononce
aussi en faveur du projet gazier selon
lui la grande majorité des entrepreneurs
et des résidents de la région se disent
prêts à appuyer le projet s'il respecte
les meilleures normes de protection de
l'environnement savoir exactement quand
on a fait à l'époque dalcan la pression
va être partout à travers le monde pour
montrer que voici les meilleures façons
avec nos jeunes avec nos ingénieurs avec
nos gens compétents on a cette capacité
là de produire des usines de qualité on
parle de 46 millions de tonnes de gaz à
10 heures c'est l'équivalent de la
consommation de 10 millions de voitures
on voit pas comment ce que de manière
crédible un élu pourrait dire je suis
pour l'environnement et en même temps
pour ce projet le fiancé le seul parc
marin du québec la coalition fiore un
groupe de citoyens de la région
s'opposent fortement au projet pour eux
cette future production de gaz va
contribuer au réchauffement de la
planète et le transport par navire
citerne sur le saguenay
mettra en danger les espèces de
mammifères marins menacés comme le
béluga
[Musique]
dans la circonscription voisine de
jonquière la vieille usine talk en fait
partie du paysage et la culture locale
depuis des lustres
la députée sortante et candidate marche
sur des oeufs
le npd joue la carte verte puis que
jamais dans la présente campagne
karinne trudel se dit prête à appuyer le
projet industriel si les promoteurs des
montres qui sera carboneutre et qu'ils
répondent aux exigences des agences de
protection d'environnement on doit
arrêter opposé les oui et les non on a
encore besoin dans plusieurs régions du
gaz naturel la transition à ce propos du
jour au lendemain
donc on doit être responsable plusieurs
pays se sont engagés à sortir du charbon
à sortir du mazeau gnl prétend que son
offre de gaz naturel va est cité des
pays comme la chine abandonné rapidement
des sources d'énergie plus polluantes
vous avez déjà des clients identifiés
vous dit en fait on a des discussions
très sérieuses
à cette étape sion n'a pas encore de
compte retenue mais pas d'acceptabilité
sociale pour le gnl québec que pour le
pai plein air
rien de transcanada le prix le projet de
gnl québec comporte un volet connexe
essentiel la construction d'un gazoduc
dans le nord de l'ontario et du québec
ce projet fait l'objet d'évaluation
environnementale indépendante de celle
qui porte sur le projet du sinn le tracé
prévoit le passage de l'énorme conduite
dans la circonscription du candidat
libéral
richard hébert tout comme sa voisine du
npd il tente de ménager la chèvre et le
chou je ne prononcerai pas sur celui qui
par ce raid sur notre territoire
parce que premièrement est ce que les
impacts sont négatifs et ce qu'ils sont
positifs
est-ce que l'emploi sur toutes ces
questions look et qui restent à résoudre
la mobilisation des environnementalistes
dépasse largement la région sacs des
aides pour l'instant le mouvement est
relativement discrète
[Musique]